the first text that i received
when dune
second movie was announced
it was a text from
senior in the desert
and i i can't wait to work with him hi
gq this is javier bardem and these are
some of my
as they say iconic characters i don't
think that they're so iconic but anyway
that's what they asked me to
say not getting any rain up here away
what way would that be i've seen you was
from dallas
what is necessity of yours
where i'm from
friend though
the challenge was to create this person
who would feel nothing he will follow
his own ethics no matter what and he
will do it against his own will i guess
that's the crazy part like if something
beyond his control or over him
is telling him how to act and still we
don't know what it is as an actor that's
the world that i kind of created for
myself to
i get justify anton shiger's actions
because in the book he's not
described as well he comes he destroys
he disappears so you have to really
understand a little bit of what's going
on in your mind in order to
execute those horrible actions like for
example in the gas station scene i was
always thinking that
there was a superior
voice and
order that was making a decision through
me
call it so this is not something
personal against that person or that
person is like
there are things that must be done in
terms of create a better world which he
thinks is a better world and in this
case it's a world where people don't
marry into businesses
they own or they earn their own
businesses
so when he says
that he it was his father's
shop he says so you marry into it
that is a change it's like wow that's
not good
and so it's unexpected but that's also
part of the karma mccarthy
words and cohen brothers brilliant
script i
need to know what i stand to win
everything
how's that you just tend to win
everything call it
i don't know because i didn't have any
interaction with any of them i was just
killing people
constantly i had a scene with woody
harrelson which it was a fun moment
because with such adorable fun caring
loving guy an amazing actor
and we had a blast doing that scene but
josh brolin
which i adore admire respect and really
worship him as a man as an actor and as
a human being really helped me so much
on a personal level in that movie
because i was going through a hard time
and uh and he really rescued me out of
it like with his humor and with his care
and attention
and presence it was the last thing i
would like to do in that moment kill him
so i had to make a big effort to try to
put my face into killing uh
legally mosh because uh
personally i love and i adore the guy
i think silva is a man that is a very
is very good at making everybody
uncomfortable and insecure
and unstable and not sure really what
what his agenda is at any level
personally physically sexually mentally
conveniently but i remember one meeting
with sam mendes which is an amazing
director a joy and a gift to work with
we sit down and we reinforce that idea
of
how can we unstable mr james bond
everything has been done already and we
said well what about the physicality
what about the sexuality what about
making sure that he really doesn't know
what to grasp we reinforce that side of
him which is beyond any gender or any
sexual
orientation is more about a person who
likes to play games
and it's hard to define see what she's
done to you
well she never tied me to a chair
her loss
i love playing that role because he was
it was a chance to really play
a villain in a james bond movie and that
gives you the freedom to try different
things but always in the frame
of reality because sam mendes is behind
the camera he wants those characters to
be real and to be honest and to be
realistic but within that you can play
around and try different things and sam
was welcome every suggestion and i love
the seeing where
the presentation of the character in the
elevator was a
pretty tough one to learn because it's
kind of scary to do that at entrance but
both sam and daniel were so supportive
and so helpful in
in me getting the confidence enough that
i needed to to play this scene and it
happened to be one of the best james
bond's movies
of all time because all the elements the
story the characters the conflict the
visuals the lining the directorial work
everything works into place and makes
a great movie beyond the gender of james
bond it's a great great movie in itself
before nightfalls was my first american
movie my first real
main role
shot in english and i didn't
know much english at the time it's not
that i know a lot now as you can tell
but
back in the day
201999
uh i was 30 years old i'm 52 years old
now and it was a great
chance that julian schnabel gave me to
portray and to play this amazing complex
role and i loved it i was immediately in
love with with rinaldo's i started to
read the books there was a time where
there was no such thing as google you
have to go to the libraries
and find the books and read the books
and talk to the people that
knew him
and do different research that you would
do today so that you can do the same or
even more from the house
of the day you have to go to places and
meet people and and i love that process
there was also a sexual revolution going
on
that came along with excitement of the
official revolution
but the drums of militarism
were still trying to beat down the
rhythm of poetry
and life
i remember being super focused on
trying to
do my best in a foreign language
and kind of unaware that it was going to
be a movie that it was going to actually
be seen by people i thought always like
it was kind of an experiment okay i'll
try to see if i can actually
perform in a foreign language let's see
how this thing goes and all of a sudden
it opened and the movie was seen and it
was very well received
and it got me absolutely by surprise but
it opened the doors to
for me to work outside spain which is a
great thing to to have because the more
opportunities you have the better for
sure if you keep writing this
you are not going to get very far
i'm going to give you five minutes
to make up your mind johnny depp he
plays two characters in the movie i
remember him being very
easy very nice very funny very
accessible very generous especially in
the second scene with uh with when he
plays a lieutenant that we shot in
julian's house actually
he did this little set in his house and
we shot it there
where ronaldo is
taking a
prisoner by him and he has
these ideas from
our imaginations
about
the sexuality of this lieutenant it
might take a queer more than five
minutes to make up his mind while
watching this handsome lieutenant stroke
his magnificent organ
and then it mixes with the reality of
the situation where he's going to be
very much punished for being
anti-revolutionary a writer and
especially a gay person that scene took
a whole day
and i loved playing with him i could
tell that he was
so easy so soft so flexible like nothing
it was a dance i love i love working
with him
yeah usball beautiful beautiful is a
movie that comes to me uh right after
the oscar
winning right yes when you win an oscar
your ground shakes a little bit like
okay what's what's next no
and i wanted to really go back and work
in my own language and they have the the
luck to have alejandro gonzalez
which is one of the best directors ever
to offer me this role and it was very
intense it is a very intense story with
a very intense character that happened
to be the first time he was working with
one
character alone rather than three
stories with three different characters
like he used to do and so we both took
the responsibility of holding the the
dramatic circumstances of this character
for so long and it was for sure one of
the most demanding stories and
characters i've ever played but i'm very
proud of what we did
we climbed the mountain and
and it's a movie about a father who
really has lost almost everything
and wants
to make sure that uh his children learn
what is
the word empathy empathy for
the ones
that are even in worse conditions that
we are
the ones that we are afraid because they
are different empathy for those who
don't have anything and even if you are
not
in the position where you can share a
lot
at least share what you got and that
will make you
and that person happier than if you
don't
[Music]
well it's one of those stories that
alejandro aminab our great director and
a beautiful man called me and i was like
i was
i was
32 and the guy was 55 when he died 56
so i was like i don't know if i can
really
uh be that person are you sure and we
took the risk so
let's try it let's let's try it
but one thing for sure that i know that
i knew and i guess he knew is that the
script the material that he wrote it was
beautifully put together it was
emotional it was intelligent and it was
cinematographic and he was going to be
also entertaining
but especially very deeply emotional
touching for the audience so i relate on
that it's okay
i just have to follow
the story
i asked have to follow him he's a great
director
and i'll try to get as close as i can to
ramon san pedro without imitating him
that's one of the things that i learned
which is
you can get close to the real person
to a to a certain point to a certain
extent because otherwise you're going to
get lost or i would get lost in the
imitation of it all
hello
i have to spend a good four hours on the
makeup i was going to say chair on the
makeup bed because the makeup has to be
done while i was laying down because
that's what we will be seeing for camera
four hours on the bed
shooting for 10-12 hours on the bed
going back home to sleep on the bed so
for three months i was on the vet and
you could see me on saturdays when they
say it's a wrap i was like
like climbing the walls and going out
and party the city like until it burns
because i i really needed to to move my
arms and but also that gives you
i use that on my favor like how it feels
to to feel trapped and to feel
i mean i was
i'm lucky and i'm blessed that i could
move but
there were moments where i felt very
impotent
of not being able to move because i
couldn't because of the movie because of
the makeup because and i felt like the
rage that
and then you multiply that for a million
and then you may have a glimpse of what
it means to be on a bed
impossible to move for 30 something
years
i love fernando leondaranova who is
one of the best screenwriters and
directors and he happens to be one of my
closest friends this is the third movie
that we do together and i
is one of those moments that when you i
read the script i have to stand up
and walk around the room because my body
was reacting to the
to how
good it is and when you read something
that good the images the layers the
details the the different colors that
the author has put into it
has a reaction a physical chemical
reaction on your body so you can read
like this you have to
and i was so happy i called him and said
i need to play this role i need to say
those lines and it's a story about the
abuse of power in in this case in a
working place it's the story of a man
who thinks of himself being the best
boss ever a colleague a partner father
to his old fellow workers it all happens
in one week and there's gonna be a
commission visiting the factory to give
an award and they are they are finalists
for the award and he wants the award
so in a week everything starts to go
really off tracks and he starts to
behave in the way he really is it's a
dark comedy
i've seen people crying laugh out loud
like
laughing their tears out
in spain and in the states and in
england and in switzerland in france i
mean the movie translate to everywhere
but there's a big big deep social
commentary in the movie that really
punches you especially at the end of the
movie where you go like oh [ __ ] was i
laughing about this and that's the
genius of fernando and it's a great
movie it has broke the record in the
goya
awards which is the oscars spanish
oscars if you want to call it we have
received 20 nominations which is huge is
big never happened before
and we are very very proud of it and
it's the spanish entry for the oscars
when i first heard about the story or or
the project was years before
and i was interested in it because i
i
knew a little bit about lucille ball but
not much about the show and then i
discovered this harness and i thought he
was such a brilliant person as a
comedian as a musician as a producer as
a colleague as an actor as a husband as
a family man as a father there were many
elements in it that made me feel like so
much uh drawn into playing him and i
chased the role i didn't check the wrong
box you saw the headline you can see the
headline from outer space then blizzard
that's how fred raised me for when i was
age four he cared about the little guy
he cared about workers rights it was a
tribute to him and they were
uh doing what what i think they should
do which is the latin representation
in movies in hollywood or out of
hollywood uh it's it's not enough and
and i support that they really go
and and try to find the actors from the
origin of of where uh where they're from
from where the characters are from
grandpa fred was wrong lucy
yes he didn't tell you the part where
they throw your father in prison for the
crime of being the mayor of the city
i was chased to this country lucy
believe me you check the wrong box
i find that respectful
and logical but i'm always saying if it
doesn't happen for any reason
i'm here because i'm going to
work and worship that fact
and commit to the role as i've always
done it and i'll try to do my best out
of respect and admiration and
hard work so when the role came to me i
was
kind of prepared because i i've read
about him for many years but when they
said now is you
i had a month and a half so i didn't
have much time to prepare for songs
conga playing guitar
and getting the
whole thing of desi and of course you
want to get as close as you can but
there's a moment where you have to give
up on that aaron told us i don't want
you guys to imitate anybody this is
about the people behind the characters
that they created
and the crnes created ricky ricardo we
are not playing ricky ricardo
so
with that in mind you start to create
the energy the essence the spirit of
what he was what he represented what he
brought to a table in terms of of
entertainment and in terms of artistry
and in terms of
a husband and
a father and you try that and
and that was a challenge to really
not listen to anything else but focus on
the work and i loved it i think it's it
was it's like it's a great movie i love
the movie and
it's like the good boss for many other
movies i feel honored and
and grateful to belong to such a great
story great movie great script and great
character it's like thank you for having
me